[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: And so we
both have a set of cards today,
and we're both going
to be asking questions.
It could be a disaster,
or it could be magical.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Normally, your stage
is one where you're critiquing
products, end results.
What would you say
to this audience
if you have an opportunity
to talk before they actually
create a product?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: What I would
say is, don't do focus groups.
Make a product that you think
is awesome and that you love.
I think the best design,
the best products,
come from really smart
people just trying
to solve their own problems,
trying to solve problems
that they really
deeply understand.
I guess what I'm saying
is follow your heart when
it comes to design.
Matias and I thought it
would be great to have
mimosas in the morning onstage.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Terrible or brilliant.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I don't
know if it was a great idea,
but they are quite delicious.
MATIAS DUARTE: I don't think so.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You can always
design your spread across lots
of different products, lots
of different breakpoints,
so how would a company
the size of Google and one
that has historically,
not known for design,
how do you get
everybody together
and start collaborating
on good design that is not
just beautiful and
useful, but that
is aligned across all
these different silos?
MATIAS DUARTE: I
think all large design
problems have to be
tackled by groups.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Does material
design become a bible at Google
for how you do design?
MATIAS DUARTE: It
becomes a guideline.
That's actually
one of the things
I think is really
interesting about creating
guidelines and
creating structures.
There's a very fine
balance between giving
too little guidance and actually
not helping people and giving
so much guidance that you
become kind of a straitjacket.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Do
you worry that we're
simplifying too much in design?
MATIAS DUARTE: I
think what you want
is a framework that
allows you to have
the conversation about
how you could simplify.
I think there's many of
these different axes that
are going to be radically
changing how we think
about our design practice, that
are going to be challenging all
the things that we think
are the fixed points of what
it is that we do as designers.
Basically, in the
exact same way I
think that you were saying
you were a print designer
and you thought you
knew how this worked.
Print, I know how to
make beautiful things.
And all of a sudden when it's
responsive, mind blown, right?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Yeah,
Matias, thanks so much.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Thank you so much.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]